[Musik]
phoenix
keine waffenruhe keine flucht korridore
nichts wurde vereinbart das erste
treffen auf regierungsebene zwischen
russland und der ukraine heute in der
türkei blieb ergebnislos und die lage
der menschen besonders in der hafenstadt
mario pohl wird immer verzweifelter und
dazu wird es noch bitterkalt im land
welchen ausweg gibt es noch die eu
staats und regierungschefs beraten zur
stunde in werl sei ein beitritt der
ukraine zur eu und der ist aber noch
lange nicht in sicht krieg in der
ukraine was kann die diplomatie noch
erreichen unser thema in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
guten abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
berlin ich darf mir meine gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist sehr gut ins kies
mitglied des europäischen parlaments für
bündnis 90 die grünen er ist in russland
geboren und hat viele beziehungen noch
zu dem land lebt aber seit 1993 schon in
deutschland und bei uns ist natalia
fiebrig sie ist auslandskorrespondentin
für den ukrainischen fernsehsender 1+1
zugeschaltet ist uns hans dieter heumann
er war diplomat auf posten in moskau
washington paris und auch bei der uno
und von 2011 bis 2015 präsident der
bundesakademie für sicherheitspolitik
und herzlich willkommen yanar polieren
sie ist leiterin des berliner büros des
european council on foreign relations
v fiebrig ich habe es eben schon gesagt
es gab eigentlich kein ergebnis heute
nach diesem treffen der beiden
außenminister
viele hatten einen hat eine hoffnung
haben gedacht vielleicht kann man etwas
vereinbaren zumindest eine waffenruhe
einen waffenstillstand hatten sie
überhaupt hoffnung oder irgendeine
erwartungen dieses treffen sowohl ich
als auch ganz viele meiner landsleute
hatten eigentlich keine großen
hoffnungen sogar würde ich sagen etwas
angst weil bisher alle vereinbarungen
getroffen worden sind oder humanitäre
korridore wurden oft zu fallen und
normalerweise sagt man wenn man redet
dann schweigen die waffen
im fall des russischen krieges gegen die
ukraine war dass er umgekehrt also
gerade wenn man in den in belarus diese
gespräche geführt hat dann hat russland
besonders hat bombardiert
darum hatte ich keine große hoffnungen
aber ich finde es trotzdem richtig dass
die ukraine mit russland auch auf diesem
wege verhandelt entspricht und was hören
sie im moment ja aus ihrer heimat was
hören sie von den menschen die eben in
der ukraine sind die sie gut kennen alle
diese situation ist furchtbar meine
schwester ist immer noch in kiew um die
versorgung ist schon da ganz schlecht
also man kommt nicht immer an
lebensmittel oder an irgendwelchen
notwendigen sachen meine freunde sind in
die nähe von kiew in butter in marcel
wurzel ist ein vorort von kiew und
bereits eingenommen das sind
tschetschenische kämpfer und das was man
hört da ich habe einfach wirklich große
angst dass es irgendwann nach kiew kommt
weil da werden zivile einfach erschossen
schon dafür wenn die irgendwie kein
essen
geben oder keine handys wenn man also
und die ukraine die sind ja so ist er
entschlossen auch zu kämpfen aber diese
situation ist grauenvoll gerade in
mariupol und mario pahl ist ja blockiert
und es gibt kein wasserversorgung es
gibt kein keine wärme es ist sehr kalt
und leute sammeln sogar schnee damit das
dauert und man etwas wasser hat und es
ist wirklich unglaublich dass es
heutzutage möglich ist und die wahl von
vor den augen der europa und der ganzen
welt und man kann es irgendwie oder
schafft es nicht es zu stoppen oder
zumindest alles zu tun damit das aufhört
wenn ist erhält man ist fassungslos
dieser angriff dieser lager lagodinsky
wenn sie das hören wenn sie dann sehen
dass da heute verhandelt wurde unter
vermittlung der türkei und letztendlich
beide außenminister dann danach
getrennte pressekonferenzen geben und
komplett andere geschichten erzählen
also hat es dann macht es dann trotzdem
noch sind kann man noch sagen es ist
trotzdem gut dass man dabei einander
sitzt ich glaube da haben da stimme ich
auch
zu ist es besser wenn man frau
miteinander reden das sind meist männer
die das jetzt machen
trotzdem hat es uns wieder heute gezeigt
also diese begegnung
das wir
praktischen parallel universen leben
dass russland mittlerweile nicht nur ein
militärisches reich sondern ein lügen
reich geworden ist sie lügen ständig und
das ist etwas was sowohl für die in den
internen verbrauch ist also sozusagen
für die eigenen bürgerinnen und bürger
aber auch dazu geeignet ist auch den
diskurs weltweit zu verseuchen ja
gewissermaßen mit diesen lügen wie zum
beispiel die lüge über das
kinderkrankenhaus was bombardiert wurde
mit der geburtsklinik und jetzt heißt es
plötzlich dass wurde nun bombardiert
weil da
terroristen oder kämpfer ukrainische
kämpfer waren obwohl wir alle gesehen
haben was die bilder und die videos uns
gezeigt haben das ist die art und weise
wie die russische propaganda
funktioniert denn wenn sogar um
außenminister wenn dann so ein treffen
aber nur sozusagen der propaganda dient
ist es dann richtig das zu tun wir sind
in einer welt der diplomatie und
parallel dazu wird gekämpft es ist ja
nicht so dass die ukrainischen die
ukrainische seite als aufgegeben hat und
wir nur auf diese treffen und nur auf
dieses diese gespräche setzen insofern
ist es gut wenn man es parallel macht
wir müssen aber als europa ganz klar
parallel sagen wir stehen fest an der
seite der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer und
wir werden weiterhin hart mit sanktionen
und mit waffenlieferungen sie
unterstützen aber die eu reden wir
natürlich gleich noch zur stunde läuft
ja der gipfel noch erhöhen wenn sie das
gesehen haben heute dieses treffen
zwischen löw und co lieber den
außenministern und man hört danach man
merkt es geht kommt gar nichts dabei
raus heißt dass die diplomatie hat
wirklich gar keine chance mehr oder ist
es dass man sagt okay wenn dann beim
nächsten mal vielleicht ist das so
nelson also ein erster schritt kann man
gibt es irgendetwas positives an diesem
zusammentreffen
ja ich würde das nicht überbewerten
also es gibt würde ich sagen
offensichtlich keine weisung
was er tun soll und ich bin auch daran
dass das russische außenministerium habe
ja dann drei jahre ist der torwart auch
gearbeitet im bunde für die wichtigen
außenpolitischen entscheidungen nicht
das gewicht hat das heißt
die
entscheidungen werden in krempel
getroffen und ich habe das gefühl dass
im augenblick eine gewisse ratlosigkeit
auch herrscht um ihre frage aufzunehmen
was kann die diplomatie noch ausrichten
sie kann auch anders ausrichten wir die
dinge bewegung sind und ich glaube die
dinge sind bewegen
denn der krieg läuft eben nicht nach
plan
und die
er wird deshalb brutalisiert die
russischen streitkräfte versuchen die
moral der bevölkerung zu brechen
wahrscheinlich weil man auch in moskau
genau weiß dass die sehr stark sind also
es gibt eine gewisse ratlosigkeit und
für künftige behandlung ist die
russische position im blick auch nicht
sehr stark denn selbst wenn die
russischen streitkräfte dort bleiben sie
haben noch keine einzige stadt und dafür
nicht fressen
eingenommen der ganze westen des landes
ist nicht unter der kontrolle
wie soll das also weitergehen ich glaube
dass er kriegt sich noch gut amüsieren
kann so zynisch es ist aber umso länger
er dauert umso unsicherer müsste
eigentlich putin über diesen verlauf des
krieges seien ich glaube dass es dann
irgendwann zu echten behandlungen frau
polieren die politik würden sie es
ähnlich positiv sehen wie rheuma das ist
eine chance gibt dass man doch irgendwie
zur verhandlung kommt da ja auch sehr
lenski ja auch eine gewisse weise gesagt
er ist muss er muss nicht mehr unbedingt
nato mitglied werden also gibt es da in
dem sinne eine kleine bewegung
ich finde ihren letzten punkt ganz
wichtig es geht ja hier auch darum
geschichten zu erzählen für
öffentlichkeiten und russland versucht
mit massiver propaganda und mit
offensichtlichen lügen
seine geschichte zu erzählen und ich
finde es wichtig dass präsident ceo
lenski in diese verhandlungen also nicht
direkt aber quasi über sein
außenminister gegangen ist und vorher
auch das signal geschickt hat dass er
bereit ist über die nato mitgliedschaft
zu diskutieren und dass er sich flexibel
gezeigt hat um eben auch so ein bisschen
diesem russischen narrativ
entgegenzuwirken dass sie keinerlei
zugeständnisse geben könnte das finde
ich ganz wichtig gleichwohl bin ich mit
herrn heumann einer meinung dass ich
glaube dass wladimir putin erst zu
zugeständnissen oder zu überhaupt zu
wirklichen verhandlungen bereit ist ich
glaube noch nicht mal an zugeständnisse
wenn er seine kriegsziele erreicht hat
also wenn er militärische erfolge
vorweisen kann wenn er auf deutsch
gesagt die ukraine noch viel mehr in die
knie gezwungen hat das ist sein ziel und
wenn er das wenn er glaubt dass er da
näher gekommen ist und seine ziele per
verhandlung durchsetzen kann und nicht
mit dem militär erst dann wird es
wirkliche verhandlungen gehen herr
lagodinsky
das war es was wir vermuten sie wie
wichtig ist dass das ja dass zum
beispiel die dass kiew fällt wenn man
das so sagen kann dass etwas tut ihm
wirklich bis dieser hauptstadt einnehmen
kann ist das dann punkt wo dann dieser
krieg vielleicht zu ende sein könnte
das wissen wir nicht weil entscheidend
ist das was im kopf von putin
stattfindet und da können einfach nicht
rein schauen also es sieht so aus als
wäre das nächste strategische ziel eben
kiew es wurde auch versucht tage und
wochen lang
zu einzukreisen und das wird die
schwierige phase seien wahrscheinlich zu
bombardieren das kommt jetzt noch auch
wenn es weh tut dass überhaupt
auszusprechen
trotzdem glaube ich dass diese
entnazifizierung legende die putin
seinen truppen mitgegeben hat weist auch
darauf hin dass kiew eingenommen werden
muss das ist eines der ziele denn man
kann nicht einen staat sozusagen
ideologisch umkrempeln ohne die
hauptstadt einzunehmen die regierung
abzusetzen und insofern glaube ich schon
dass er zumindest symbolisch dieses ziel
erreichen muss um dann im nächsten
schritt zu sagen okay dann
habe ich zumindest ein ziel erreicht und
kann auch dann verhandeln das wäre eine
große tragödie wenn jemand aus moskau
kiew einnimmt das ist natürlich für die
beiden völker einen traum hat was über
jahrhunderte lang dieser beziehung
belasten wird daraufhin will was
befürchten sie da er für die nächsten
tage auch
ich befürchte das gift zu einem zweiten
mario pohl werden kann oder zu einem
längengrade unter der blockade der
deutschen
im zweiten weltkrieg dass da wirklich
gar nichts mehr durchkommt ich habe
wirklich keine große angst dass es zu
sehr schmutzigen blick wert was
eigentlich ist schon ist weil wir sehen
dass pushen sich um zivilisten überhaupt
nicht schert und sich sogar vermuten
gezielt auch versucht dass die russische
armee gezielt die zivilisten
bombardiert um ebendiese wille zu
brechen und angst zu verbreiten
weil man vielleicht diese widerstand
gegen solche wasser in der ukraine gar
nicht erwarten hat
ich würde vermuten dass putin auch
falsch in front also entweder lebte in
einem eigenen welt und in eine eigene
legende oder wirklich wird der falsch
informiert und
ich glaube so die diese diese
enttäuschung kann jetzt kann wirklich
gegen den zivilisten auch einsetzen und
das ist meine große angst dass sehr
viele leute sterben kann man
man hat ja den eindruck oder die werde
die frage wer eigentlich noch einfluss
haben könnte auf putin und wer ihn berät
und die ist ja die frage ob er überhaupt
wirklich genau weiß was in der ukraine
läuft was ist da ihre vermutung also
funktioniert das dass das jemand so
isoliert ist und eigentlich nicht sieht
dass es eben nicht so läuft wie er sich
ursprünglich vorgenommen hatte
ja es gibt leute es gibt ja steht
also einer e mail die entourage die
samen haben kommt nicht mehr an ihn ran
und man
kann natürlich nur spekulieren oder man
schaut in die geschichte wo das
eigentlich auch so war dass diktatoren
denn putin ist inzwischen nicht mehr
einfach ein autoritär sondern im grunde
wird das system der direkten an die
diktatur das dass es auf diese tendenz
hat man das und die nicht mehr richtig
beraten dass ich wollte aber noch diesem
zusammenhang auch frau coleen sagte wenn
die kriegsziele reich sind verhandlungen
ich möchte doch nur mal feststellen weil
ich von bewegung sprach dass die
ursprünglichen kriegsziele die guten
angegeben hat nämlich
entwaffnung der gesamten ukraine und
entnazifizierung also regierungswechsel
ist dass ich nicht glaube dass er die
überhaupt noch erreicht ich bin noch
nicht sicher ob es gibt hier nach zwei
wochen keine straßenkämpfe diese kolonne
steht stellt also ich glaube dass die
ursprünglichen kriegsziele nicht
erreicht werden sie werden auch nicht
mehr erwähnt von putin stattdessen lässt
die sprecherin des außenministers die
international steht die frau sei aber
verlauten dass ein regierungswechsel gar
nicht mehr angestrebt ist also ich
wiederhole ratlosigkeit bewegung die
ursprünglichen ziele werden auf keinen
fall erreicht man muss auch über den
krieg hinausgehen vor dem mann ausgesagt
dass sie keinen krieg vorhaben also ich
würde da nicht zu viel
hineininterpretieren und glauben alles
was frau seehofer sagt erst recht nicht
wahr sie sagt dass sie lügen maschinen
oder uns dies ist da uns zu verwirren
große frau coleen und das obwohl er in
mitte
ich wäre auch vorsichtig jetzt schon
beurteilen zu können wie die
erfolgsaussichten der russischen armee
wirklich sind ich finde auch den
widerstand den die ukraine leisten
unglaublich beeindruckend und ist im
westen und in russland unterschätzt
worden
und ich glaube es kommt jetzt darauf an
dass wir gerade im westen die
unterstützung der ukraine
aufrechterhalten auch was die
waffenlieferungen betrifft und dass wir
alles daran setzen dass die ukrainische
armee weiter erfolgreich ist ich glaube
trotzdem wir sollten die russische armee
nicht unterschätzen die bilder die wir
momentan
sehen oder auch die nach aachen gekommen
sind sehr gefärbt und ich würde
vorsichtig sein zu sagen dass die russen
diesen krieg nicht mehr gewinnen wollen
ich glaube was wir sehen werden in den
nächsten tagen und wochen ist eine
massive
ein massiver kampf gegen die
zivilbevölkerung einer ausweitung des
kampfes ein versuch auch das
funktionieren der städte zu unterbinden
indem man strom wasser die versorgung
grundsätzlich lahm ist also alles das
was normales öffentliches leben ausmacht
und dass man dass man wirklich weiter
versucht einzuschüchtern und zu
terrorisieren wir wissen dass es waffen
dass waffen benutzt worden sind die
völkerrechtlich geächtet sind und ich
würde einfach die brutalität russlands
nicht unterschätzen herr neumann hat
einen punkt dass es schwierig ist sich
zu
auszumalen wie das dauerhaft gehen soll
also selbst wenn man militärisch quasi
die ukraine
wenn marie liegt obwohl das neue das
neue modell ist der russischen
kriegsführung dann ist ja die frage wie
man trotzdem immer das land besetzt den
unweigerlich folgern verfolgenden
partisanenkampf wie man dem herr werden
will als russland aber ich glaube dass
russland noch lange nicht bereit ist
eine niederlage einzugestehen putin hat
gesagt er will diesen krieg gewinnen und
ich glaube das ist die russische armee
noch zu ganz anderen fähig sein wenn das
aber so ist dann müssen wir dann ist ja
die frage können wir dann zu schauen
weiter und müssen wir dann nicht auf
andere art eingreifen auch profis wird
immer wieder gefordert von präsident
lenzen die flugverbotszone da sagt der
westen ganz klar das können wir nicht
machen dann greifen wir so stark ein
dass wir einen dritten weltkrieg
provozieren also
wie was erwarten sie denn dann wenn das
wenn das ist wenn das eintritt wie sie
es ja sagen die frau coleen auch sagt
dieser harte krieg gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
das ist eben die frage wie lange auch
der westen das aushält
diese bilder zu sehen und ja
also ich würde sogar vermuten dass man
möglicherweise zu diese frage
flugverbotszone doch zurückkommen wird
und ja das klingt jetzt von seiten der
nato von amerikaner absolut
ausgeschlossen
aber das haben wir auch vor einigen
wochen aus deutschland gehört keine
waffenlieferungen und dann ist der klick
eingetreten und man hat jetzt doch eine
andere position also das würde ich
hoffen dass hoffentlich ganz viele
ukraine das ist das was was man nicht
ständig fragt
eine andere geschichte sind auch
sanktionen also auch hier sehe ich dass
man etwas zögerlich handelt und dass
diese zeitenwende ehe gesprochen sehr
harte sanktion das stimmt sind es dauert
einfach bis die wirkung zu rennen
in der zwischenzeit wird der bond und ja
und erschossen und ermordet ich glaube
deutschland kann sich sehr wohl leisten
jetzt ein embargo auf eine die
lieferungen zu verabschieden und auch
jetzt was sich in der bevölkerung in der
deutschen bevölkerung sie diese welle
der solidarität also dass das spürt man
wirklich sehr wohl inwieweit leute hier
auch erschrocken sind davon was man
heutzutage sehen und er vermutlich
könnte man das auch nutzen um zu
vermitteln dass auch frieden in europa
ein reifenteil und labors wie sehen sie
es also sie haben immer sie waren immer
gegen nord stream 2 und sich dagegen
ausgesprochen jetzt könnte man jetzt
sagen man macht das wie die usa
und gas lieferungen stoppen das ist ja
in der eu noch weiter umstritten und wie
würden sie denn sagen wir waren auch und
sind weiterhin dafür dass wir uns von
der abhängigkeit von fossilen also von
öl gas
von der russischen von den russischen
lieferungen auch befreien aber das ist
ein transformationsprozess der dauert ja
wir haben nie gesagt das muss man von
einem tag auf den anderen machen und das
ist glaube ich die herausforderung jetzt
man kann das eingehen man kann das
machen aber in den usa ist der anteil
des russischen öls
775 bei uns ist das
35.000
ja aber so eine geschichte wie gestern
mit der geburtsklinik die hat so viele
menschen so erschüttert wenn es solche
geschichte wie sie sagen man muss sich
auf ein etwas einstellen wie wir leben
den grad im zweiten weltkrieg wenn wir
weiter diese bilder sehen von den von
diesen verzweifelt wenn von diesem
schlimmen verbrechen glauben sie nicht
dass der druck dann wächst auch aus der
bevölkerung absolut zu sagen wir wollen
kein gas und öl von russland ich glaube
absolut dass dieser druck wächst auch
von außen selbstverständlich auch der
moralische druck wächst und ich schließe
das nicht aus aber das können wir nicht
einfach so ohne berechnungen ohne ersatz
ohne strategie machen und so wie ich das
unseren ministerien unsere
bundesregierung verstehe werden auch
strategien entwickelt allerdings
es ist auch nicht richtig zu sagen dass
wir nun zu schauen das ist auch falsch
wir liefern waffen die eu hat gerade
auch im rat beschlossen anfang dieser
woche dass noch mehr waren defensiv
warten ja aber das sind genau die waffen
die die ukrainer so stark machen dass
wir die weiter liefern und wir haben
sanktionen und die größte die
unerwartete sanktionen die wir verhängt
haben war die isolierung der zentralbank
von russland damit hat russland 0
gerechnet und das bedeutet dass wir bis
mitte april wahrscheinlich einen default
also ein staatsbankrott in russland
haben werden die ganzen westlichen
unternehmen verlassen russland es ist
eine endlose implosion des staats und
des finanzsystems dieses staates und
deswegen und das kostet uns auch schon
was ja deswegen finde ich wir sollten
das nicht zerreden und nicht kleinreden
das was der westen jetzt macht
waffenlieferungen habe ich immer schon
gesagt wann nötig vielleicht sogar vor
dem krieg wäre es noch besser gewesen
aber
es gibt auch grenzen und die
flugverbotszonen ist ein board ein
begriff aber de facto bedeutet dass luft
krieg mit russland es wird kein es gibt
keine luft verbotszone über der ukraine
wenn russen zur zeit die luft
kontrollieren das bedeutet einen krieg
zwischen der nato und russland und zur
zeit ist keiner bereit das einzugehen
weil das bedeutete der dritte den
dritten weltkrieg und das bedeutet
wahrscheinlich auch die gefahr einer
nuklearen konfrontation das macht es für
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer auch
nicht viel besser
was wie viel
was denken sie wie stark diese
sanktionen wirklich wirken und wie viel
erfolg versprechen sie sich davon
die sanktionen wirken das sieht man
jetzt zum beispiel der lagedienst dass
er richtig dargestellt dass zum beispiel
die capo testa lokal mit der zentralbank
den rubel von in den freien fall
gebracht hat in sehr kurzer zeit und 50
prozent da sein der wert verloren das
spürte bevölkerung gesichert hat auch er
anfängt schon zu fragen was lisa krieg
soll also sanktionen wirken übrigens
auch die
deportationen bei
bei sensiblen
technologien
russland ist auch bei der
energiegewinnung wenn komplizierte
energiewende auf short zum beispiel zu
90 prozent von westlicher technologie
dann abhängig das sind alles dinge die
wird man fragt sich wie lange eigentlich
die oligarchen die mit sanktionen
überzogen werden die ihre loyalität zu
gut die noch halten also ich bin sehr
für diesen druck zu erheben einem moment
offensichtlich der unsicherheit man muss
also den kriegsverlauf hinausgehen und
wenn man davon ausgeht dass putin außer
seiner obsession mit der ukraine ist
ebenso ein machterhalt geht dann sind
die sanktionen wichtig weil hier ein
schwaches system putin einig noch weiter
geschwächt wird und wäre denn dann es
sinnvoll wenn die eu auch sagen würde
wir stoppen den energie import von
russland
die eu und sicherheit bereit uns
entschieden dass der
energie import die abhängigkeit und zwei
drittel dieses jahr verringert wird aber
die eu muss natürlich verschiedenen
ländern entscheiden aber auch italien
dass er abhängig ist hat eine andere
haltung als wir hierzu wollte was mich
überrascht oder dass sich interessant
findet das in deutschland
wissenschaftliche institutionen wie zum
beispiel die leopoldina sagt die ein
stockwerk reporter ist hunter handball
aber die politik etwas anderes sagt also
dass es gibt auch in diesem feld der
politische aussagen und
wissenschaftlicher frau pohl was denken
sie wie schnell wird der druck auch von
der bevölkerung hier wachsen dass das
dann dass die eu das die bundesregierung
einfach noch vielleicht nicht aktivere
rolle einnimmt
um diesen krieg zu stoppen ich denke der
druck wird wachsen und die umfragen in
der bevölkerung sind ja sehr positiv was
sozusagen die leidensfähigkeit oder die
leidensbereitschaft deutschen angelangt
es gibt mehrere umfragen der jüngsten
zeit wo die deutsche bevölkerung
explizit gefragt wurde ob sie bereit ist
auch persönliche einbußen
hinzunehmen wenn es denn zum schaden
russlands ist und da war die
bereitschaft sehr groß ich glaube die
politik ist deswegen zögerlich weil es
vor allen dingen nicht darum geht um
einen ausfall in diesem winter noch zu
kompensieren sondern weil das problem
sein wird dass es im sommer nicht
gelingt die speicher zu erfüllen
insbesondere die gasspeicher das heißt
das große problem wird vor allen dingen
die versorgung im nächsten winter sein
und das ist natürlich eine sehr lange
zeit auch in einem politischen kontext
mit vielen unwägbarkeiten deswegen
glaube ich dass die politik zögerlich
ist ich finde trotzdem dass das eine
moralische verpflichtung ist die wir
jetzt eingehen sollen ich habe dafür
plädiert und plädiere da auch weiter
dafür wir dürfen uns allerdings nicht
der illusion hingeben dass das jetzt
ganz ganz schnell
konsequenzen hat und der das regime
fallen wird ich glaube das regime steht
unter das regime putin steht unter sehr
großem innenpolitischen druck aber wir
wissen ganz wenig nur über die dynamiken
im kreml und vor allen dingen wissen wir
nicht wer danach kommt ich glaube wir
müssen uns von dieser idee verabschieden
das quasi der liberale pro demokratisch
russische befreiten nur auf seine chance
warten putin hat viele kontrahenten
bewusst ausgeschaltet zuletzt alexej
nawalny der jetzt in einer strafkolonie
sitzt das hatte ja system und wir ich
glaube auch ein szenario wenn putin feld
und das regime zusammenbricht muss nicht
nur positiv für uns sein das kann sehr
viel instabilität nach sich ziehen die
nachfolge kann sehr umkämpft sein und
ich glaube wir müssen uns jetzt auch auf
diese szenarien schon vorbereiten was
tun wir im falle eines regimes heißt es
reagieren
sie das würde ja auch heiß oder das ist
ganz wichtig ist irgendwie kontakt zu
halten und irgendwie zu versuchen nicht
alle brücken abzubauen es gibt ja
eigentlich ganz viele deutsch russische
projekte auch oder europäisch russische
projekt städtepartnerschaften all das
sie haben sie kennen viele menschen in
russland viele auch aus der elite will
gibt es dann möglich jetzt sehen sie
irgendeine chance das sieht das von der
zivilbevölkerung irgendein der eindruck
entsteht dass man sagt ja dass man gegen
putin aufsteht es gibt ermutigende
positive zeichen wir haben ja gesehen
die demonstrationen wir haben gesehen
dass tausende von dem demonstrieren dann
die gegen den krieg demonstriert haben
oder hatten wurden danach verhaftet aber
man muss auch sagen spätestens nach der
schließung der letzten zwei sendern als
ein tv sender und ein radiosender die
überhaupt wahrheit über diesen krieg
gesagt haben und nach der veränderung
des straff des strafgesetzbuches wonach
jetzt jede wahrheit über diesen krieg
mit bis zu 15 jahren
gefängnis strafe bestraft werden kann
und übrigens auch alle die mit
sanktionen flirten ja also die
sanktionen überall sich überlegen oder
oder befürworten
seitdem gibt es einen exodus praktisch
alle menschen mit gewissen
die die elite dieses landes ausgemacht
haben die intellektuelle elite die
zivilgesellschaft die sind alle
praktisch draußen und mit denen habe ich
auch kontakt sie suchen übrigens auch
nach möglichkeiten asyl zu bekommen
irgendwo unterzukommen auch daran an
diese leute aus russland und aus belarus
müssen wir denken und schauen dass wir
für sie möglichkeiten hier in der eu
schaffen hier in sicherheit zu leben
aber das ist um das noch mal zu
beantworten die hoffnung die letzte
hoffnung die wir hatten die ist
ausgewandert letzte woche noch das ist
bitter das heißt es da gibt es auch
keine kontakte von seiten der ukraine
mit zu versuchen dass man damit mit
großem die gegen den krieg sind dass es
dafür verbindungen gibt es gibt es das
ist ganz interessant sogar es gibt hier
ganz viele verbindungen und familien
verwandten in russland meine familie
selbst so wir haben verwandte in moskau
und die die haben sich nicht mal
interessiert www wie es uns geht
das ist schlimmer wenn man mit ihm
telefoniert und erzählt was los ist
hatte sich ackermann das ist das ist gar
nicht so wir haben das im fernsehen ganz
anders gesehen und erwartet jetzt
befreit von den nazis und ihr werdet gar
nicht also das ist und an sich
es gibt in deutschland diese und von der
deutschen regierung die so negativ dass
es den krieg von putin und nicht russen
dann würde ich eigentlich nicht
zustimmen wir haben von den russen viel
mehr erwartet ja es gab demonstrationen
aber da waren 1000 menschen tausende
aber fürs land mit 140 millionen
einwohner das ist eigentlich fast gar
nichts ich glaube wer putin zum fallen
bringen kann und das haben die ukraine
von den russen erwarten sind die russen
selbst
aber ich sehe da nicht mal die
möglichkeit die sie nicht ergreifen
wollen ich sehe gar nicht den wunsch
okay das ist bitter wie wichtig wäre es
dass die ukraine eine perspektive in der
eu bekommt der hey mann aber wir haben
jetzt der gipfel läuft noch in
versailles und es heißt dort die ukraine
ist teil der europäischen familie aber
es ist auch klar es gibt eigentlich
keine perspektive auf einen beitritt ist
das richtig
ja diese formulierung ist in der tat
ziemlich schwach ich weiß nicht ob die
sich jetzt noch er ändert man kann sich
zurückziehen und einfach beschreiben wie
das abläuft nummer also das kommt jetzt
erst die kommission und wird ein oder
zwei jahre brauchen um einen gutachter
abzugeben doch das über die ukraine die
chance hat die kopenhagener kriterien zu
erfüllen und dann müssen die die
regierung city
gehört also die regierungschefs
beschließen auf zehn kandidaten also so
läuft ab und da kann man sich
zurückziehen und sagen dass da noch aber
ich möchte folgendes sagen es gibt ja in
der geschichte der europäischen
integration in den 80er jahren in
deutschland so der regierung kohl und
genscher
jeden ansatz da ging es um artikel um
griechenland und spanien die eine
diktatur hinter sich hatten mit dieser
perspektive einer mitgliedschaft einfach
zu ermutigen sich zu transformieren also
es gibt durchaus beispiele für
politische entscheidungen für politische
signale für ein solches land gesetzt
werden und das finde ich ist bei der
ukraine mehr als angebracht vor allem
wenn
vor allem wenn wenn es verhandlungen
gibt die
die die nato mitgliedschaft der ukraine
in die ferne rücken oder unmöglich
machen aber die eu eine
eine größere rolle spielen außerdem wird
ja gerade über den strategischen kompass
der europäischen union der wirt 24 märz
verabschiedet und der hat auch
sicherheitspolitische elemente die man
dann im umgang zum beispiel des
institute partnerschaften
sicherheitspartnerschaften dass man auch
für die ukraine nutzen kann also ich bin
für einsteiger ist natürlich richtig mal
bill an die an die ukraine frau bringen
ich darf ich da was zu sagen setzte weil
ich finde dass
ich kann aus vollem herzen verstehen
warum man ein positives signal an die
ukraine senden will aber wenn man jetzt
quasi sagt gut wir nehmen sie nicht in
die nato auf weil wir als nato und nicht
bereit sind die ukraine zu schützen was
die nato ja relativ klar gemacht hat
dann kann man sie auch nicht in die eu
aufnehmen die eu hat mit dem artikel 42
7 eine beistands klausel das heißt wer
in der europäischen union ist hat dient
ein anrecht auf den schutz der anderen
mitgliedstaaten das ist eine
militärische sicherheitsgarantie und das
ist ein punkt den ich mir vorstellen
kann dass ein land was ich auf absehbare
zeit in einem konflikt befinden wird
wird unter diesen umständen nicht in die
eu aufgenommen werden die die ukraine
kann auch nur dann aufgenommen werden
wenn es quasi
prinzip die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt
und russland diesen krieg verliert der
meydan 2014
ging ja darum ein assoziierungsabkommen
mit der eu zu schließen und die alexion
der krim ist ja in reaktion darauf
erfolgt auf diese protest und auf diesen
pro-europäischen
impuls der aus der ukraine hervor ging
und ich glaube nicht nach allem wie ich
wladimir putin verstanden habe und den
aufsatz den er im letzten sommer
geschrieben hat wo es ihm darum ging das
russische imperium wiederzubeleben und
die ukraine und die russen sind ein volk
ich glaube nicht dass er eine
eu-mitgliedschaft tolerieren würde und
das sollten wir nicht vergessen
und noch ein letzter punkt ich glaube
auch wir müssen uns auch darüber im
klaren sein dass es im endeffekt dann
die parlamente in den mitgliedstaaten
werden die über die eu mitgliedschaft
entscheiden würden plus mindestens in
frankreich wird es ein referendum geben
mit unklarem ausgang die niederländer
haben das assoziierungsabkommen mit der
ukraine vielleicht unter anderen
bedingungen aber damals abgelehnt ich
wollte damit nur ein bisschen wasser in
den wein gießen man kann einen ein
ermutigendes signal senden ich verstehe
das aber ich habe große angst dass man
in der ukraine auch wieder einmal
hoffnung weckt mit lippenbekenntnissen
und die dann niemand dann nicht
aufrechterhalten möchte was sagen sie
dazu wie groß ist die gefahr dass man ja
eben diese hoffnung weckt das dann nicht
umsetzen kann und wenn man auf eine
längerfristige ja überlegen will wie
sortiert sich dieses europa auch im
verhältnis zu russland das ist dann
eigentlich ehrlicher wäre zu sagen die
ukraine sollen nicht in die eu
ich glaube nicht ich glaube wir sind in
prozessen
im vertraglichen prozessen und in
historischen prozessen und die welt
verändert sich aber das bedeutet eben
dass wir nicht von heute auf morgen
leider muss man sagen aber wir können
nicht dem ruf des ukrainischen
präsidenten folgen und sagen jetzt
vergeben wir eben die socken
kandidatenstatus sondern wir können
ermutigende zeichen trotzdem setzen das
was wir vom parlament gemacht haben was
von der leyen auch gesagt hat wir
glauben daran dass irgendwann in der
zukunft einer mitgliedschaft möglich ist
und wir starten diesen prozess aber wenn
frau polieren mit dieser
beitrittsklausel dass das ist dann eben
auch bei russland wird ja auch
irgendwann anders sein hoffentlich ja
und und die ukraine wird auch irgendwann
anders sein irgendwann werden die
kopenhagener kriterien auch da erfüllt
sein also ich glaube diesen prozess
können wir durchaus staaten in der
zuversicht dass die welt sich auch
verändert und vielleicht auch zum
besseren verändert und wir alles
unterliegt hatten wir nicht lange lacko
dienst resigniert wir sind jetzt sehr
negativ eingeholt worden von einer sehr
brutalen wirklich und deswegen werden
wir es nicht von heute auf morgen machen
aber wir können dem ukrainischen volk
und wir schulden der ukrainischen volk
ein zeichen dass sie nicht umsonst auf
mai dann gestorben sind weil sie wollten
eine europäische perspektive und dass
sie jetzt auch nicht umsonst sterben das
bedeutet aber nicht dass wir jetzt schon
einen kandidaten stadt vergeben dass es
nicht vorgesehen von unseren prozessen
her also ich glaube eine mischung aus
ein zeichen dass zuversicht und trotzdem
und das wir treu bleiben denn prozessen
und den verträgen die wir haben und das
dauert nun mal ein bisschen länger diese
mischung müssen wir glaubwürdig und
glaubhaft vermitteln frau fiebrig kommt
das an bei ihnen ja genau ich würde
sagen das wäre ein richtiger weg was
jetzt die mögliche reaktionen aus moskau
sein könnte würde ich sagen putin
braucht keine anlass
um seine aggression zu steigern und es
ist einfach ein anderes ratio in moskau
es wurde immer in fasten auch versucht
zu analysieren wie eher darauf oder auf
was anderes reagieren würde ich glaube
das einfach falsch also die die die
politische analyse in deutschland war
auch vor diesem krieg komplett falsch
und ich würde nicht sagen also ich würde
nicht glauben dass sie jetzt wegen des
kandidatenstatus für die ukraine putin
irgendwie anders reagieren würde also
die endlich stimmt aber
leider leider die enttäuschung auch ist
da also man man man hat doch die europa
macht hier aber man hat auch mehr
erwartet
und das ist einfach schade also die
ukraine werden kann von mit oder ohne
kandidatenstatus man kämpft eigentlich
für das eigene land aber man sieht sich
auch in europa man sind sich auch im
vereinten europa und diese signal war
unheimlich wichtig eben zum die klare
europäische perspektive würde ich so
sagen okay bekommen wir noch mal darauf
was man da wir noch eine kurz jahres
note dazu noch machen ja
ich würde mir wünschen wenn wir dieses
zeichen denn jetzt sind dass wir dann
auch wirklich dabei bleiben und auch
wirklich uns dazu bekennen weil im
prinzip erzählen wir der ukraine ja seit
2014 wenn ihr euch nur gut genug
anstrengt und wenn sich die weltlage
verändert natürlich könnt ihr irgendwann
mitglied der nato werden natürlich könnt
ihr irgendwann die der europäischen
union werden und das war genau diese
zwischen lage dieses ihr habt diese
perspektive aber jetzt noch nicht wie
ich finde sehr schädlich war auch weil
sie sehr viele falsche hoffnungen
geweckt hat weil jetzt die enttäuschung
eben sehr sehr groß ist und ich finde
wenn man sagt man bekennt sich jetzt
dazu dann dann muss man dem auch taten
folgen lassen und dann müsste man aber
vielleicht gleichermaßen auch anderen
beitrittskandidaten die sehr sehr lange
schon warten im westlichen balkan zum
beispiel auch eine schnellere
beitrittsperspektive geben und für mich
sind das kann jetzt nichts
auch wenn krieg in der ukraine herrscht
quasi einen sonder mitgliedschaft für
die ukraine hatte auch gesagt dann mach
es nochmal etwas konkrete erhöhen wenn
man jetzt versucht doch irgendwie
gespräche zu vermitteln versucht
irgendwie der diplomatie eine chance zu
geben was könnte man denn putin anbieten
gibt es etwas wo man sagen kann dass
während und richtiger ja das wäre eine
möglichkeit dass man da irgendwie weiter
kommt
ja ich erinnere daran dass
vor diesem krieg gab es ja russische
vorschläge
amerikanische gegenvorschläge also wenn
es mal zu wirklich seriösen
verhandlungen kommt über die grundfragen
über die russischen
sicherheitsinteressen
dann glaube ich dass man auch dass man
im grunde eine balance von zwei
prinzipien finden muss die beide seiten
unterschrieben haben wir betonen immer
sehr die das prinzip der freien
bündnisfall war es in der charta von
paris steht und was völlig richtig ist
der vergessen manchmal dass in dem nato
russland antrag zum beispiel auch das
prinzip der gemeinsamen sicherheit also
dass das vieh sicherheit dass ein nicht
auf kosten des anderen gegen hat man
kann also sagen wir mal auf der burg
laage und bezieht man eine gewisse
eine gewissen konsens herstellen und
dann über fragen der ausgestaltung der
militärischen präsenz verhandeln also
ich schließe nicht aus dass es wieder zu
diese behandlung kommen die ja schon mal
versucht er worden bevor dieser krieg
begonnen hat so sofern sie den ernst
genommen werden und wir haben
komischerweise bis jetzt gar nicht über
den
vorschlag von zilien ski über diesen
begriff der kollektiven sicherheits
vereinbarung den er selbst vorgeschlagen
hat nicht an berater er selbst die
nichts anderes ist dass einige ist eine
art neutralität als die jungs um bessere
begriff geht die aber garantiert wird
und anderen so in eher
besser
ich finde ich finde es nur strange und
sehr seltsam dass wir ein land was mit
streubomben mit brandbomben eine
aggression betreibt gegen ein anderes
land und wir nicht mal einer verbots
flugverbotszone verhängen wollen weil
wir angst haben vor einer konfrontation
mit diesem land dass wir über
sicherheitsgarantien an diesen aggressor
abgeben müssen dieser krieg beweist doch
dass es nicht noch mehr sicherheit für
russland geben kann also es gibt
russland kann machen was es will in
seiner in dieser gegend und deswegen
klar eine abrüstung das was wir auch
schon betrieben haben aber jetzt nicht
überhöhen die bedeutung der
sicherheitsgarantien für russland
russland braucht keine
sicherheitsgarantien russland schafft
fakten aber sie hat ja selber spiel
gebracht wenn wenn ihr demokratische
regierung das unter diesen bedingungen
schweren bedingungen selbst ins spiel
bringt dann müssen wir es respektieren
aber wir müssen es auch nicht
herbeireden
und wir müssen auch nicht vor russland
sozusagen auf die knie fallen und suchen
nach lösungen die moskau beruhigt das
ist der falsche zeitpunkt frage ist ja
ich werde da wir nur noch zwei minuten
wir haben nur noch zwei minuten weil ich
würde gerne noch ein ganz zum schluss
nochmal einmal fragen weil es jetzt sehr
viel aufregung darüber gibt dass ex
bundes der altbundeskanzler schröder
nach moskau gefahren ist so putin gibt
es berichte darüber frau fiebrig dass er
da hingefallen seine frau hat ein bild
aus moskau gepostet also ist das ist das
was wo sie sagen es ist gut wenn er da
hinfährt und vermitteln
eigentlich wird gerhard schröder in die
ukraine gar nicht mehr ernst genommen
dass so eine ja
quasi ein bild der korruption und
arbeitet also sozusagen die mitarbeiter
von denen aber weil er möglicherweise
dem russischen präsidenten der reale
bild das wir alle bild präsentiert dann
ja wenn das zu einem ergebnis führt dann
meinetwegen wie sehen sie die
regulierung solle doch versuchen aber
das entschuldigt auf keinen fall seiner
rolle in den letzten jahrzehnten denn er
hat uns dieser fatale abhängigkeit von
russland was die fossilen angeht
beschert und er bleibt dafür
verantwortlich aber er soll es versuchen
das alles was uns frieden bringt
begrüßen wir alle vielleicht polieren
noch ganz kurz einmal ganz kurz dazu
einfach nur einen satz ich stelle mein
vorredner rennen zu
sehen sie eine chance jetzt schwerer
fällt mir nicht leicht
der titel der sendung kriegt ja die
diplomatie in sich und natürlich muss
man die kunden sagen irgendwann wieder
auf den tisch bringen das wäre sollte
missverständnis der möglichkeiten die
formation okay gut dann hoffen wir dass
die diplomatie tatsächlich noch eine
chance hat mit wem auch immer wäre es
noch schafft so vermitteln vielen dank
herr lagodinsky hollmann frau polier und
frau fiebrig und vielen dank liebe
zuschauer fürs interesse jetzt geht es
weiter mit phoenix der tag in schönen
abend noch bis dann
[Musik]